pues como os podéis imaginar se hasta
ahora la seguridad era máxima
mucho más recordar en washington no
solamente están los trama noche también
llegaron by the new wyden y su esposa y
también participará en el evento de hoy
las familias es presidencia el lunes
clinton you gama también a la formación
a de washington el cine encontrarse uno
de estos controles de seguridad tienen a
mis espaldas es prácticamente imposible
todas las calles están cerradas variadas
y tomadas por esos militares por esos 25
mil militares
eso es alan cinco veces más de los que
hay ahora mismo desplegados en irak y
afganistán para que se hagan una idea
hay 13 líneas de metro cerrada también
se hace se ha cerrado el famoso nacional
humor y se está investigando registrando
a todo el mundo de manera aleatoria
incluso a esos 25 mil militares que
participarán en la protección del evento
todo a raíz de que se haya descubierto
que entre los asaltantes del pasado 6 de
enero el capitolio había algunos seis
veteranos y agentes de la policía
ya esta extrema seguridad en washington
tras el asalto al capitolio se le añade
que el evento no tendrá tampoco público
por la pandemia mamen que ya deja más de
400.000 muertes en el país cuáles son
las medidas tomadas para prevenir los
contagios
si harán desde luego esta renovación de
la democracia se va a hacer en un clima
completamente enrarecido como decías
debido a esas medidas anti kobe de los
200.000 asistentes que suele haber en
una ceremonia de toma de posesión solo
va a haber mil personas fuera dentro del
capitolio fuera en la calle la imagen
también va a ser muy diferente no va a
haber público esa plaza es en national
moon que os comentaba que suele estar
lleno de cientos de miles de ciudadanos
que viajan hasta washington para seguir
de cerca este día tan importante hoy no
lo harán la alcaldesa de la ciudad ha
pedido a los estadounidenses que no
viajen hasta la capital
en su lugar ese national molt estará
decorado con más de 191.000 banderas
estadounidenses y como podéis imaginar
mascarilla obligatoria el desfile se
retransmitirá de manera virtual y ese
baile y baile inaugural que suele haber
para cerrar este día pues se va a
sustituir por un programa de televisión
de cerca de 90 minutos que estará
presentado por el actor tom hanks